Mike Pompeo is making pretty clear that
he wants to run for president against
Donald Trump and it's interesting to
keep an eye on who's kind of considering
a challenge to Trump within the
Republican Party Mike Pompeo was the
Secretary of State under Donald Trump
here is a moment from Fox News where he
didn't even try to conceal the fact that
yes he's planning on running process is
kind of lay that out people get a chance
to say whoa this this is huge
um so there is a educational element
that is important as well in the end you
got to pay your bills I am confident
that the United States government will
do so I only worry that we will not
begin to change the trajectory of the
American economy by growing it and the
American and American spending by
reducing it in the meantime you're
running for president aren't you
okay good throw O'Neill uh nice try
um yeah I like that I I like that a
little passive aggressive perfect look
we're doing all the things that one
would do to get to get ready
um but we're still trying to figure our
way we're doing all of the things that
one would do to get ready well that's
pretty clear breakthrough we don't have
anything to announce today or would it
be impacted At All by Donald Trump I
mean he is running he's the only
announced candidate uh you know you
worked with him and obviously he has
said of Ron DeSantis of course if he
runs it he's to paraphrase it would be a
little disloyal he's done a lot for them
do you feel that way
oh goodness no
um I was incredibly loyal to America and
to the work that President Trump wanted
done the American people will decide who
the next Republican nominee is and
anybody who throws their hat in the ring
has the responsibility to go out compete
make their case make the arguments to
the people of Iowa New Hampshire and
South Carolina and let the American
people sort through who they think
usually even right before someone
announces they still do the I'm not
thinking about 2024 answer he's going
yeah so we're doing everything to
prepare but I don't have an announcement
right now Okay cool so you're running
and we're waiting on announcement but
what's interesting is Mike Pompeo for a
while now has been making clear that he
wants to run and this whole time I
haven't understood
why he thinks that he's likely to do
well I just don't see him as someone who
could carry a lot of support within the
Republican party because you either have
to be a trumpster which Trump feels
right because he's running or
a really
kind of on the fence trumpster here's
what I mean and it's kind of just a
santis it's the only person who fits
this mold if you're going to do well on
the Republican primary all of these
individuals I wish would not be
president but within this context
DeSantis appeals to the radicals and
appeals more radical than even Trump
sometimes with his vaccine comments
right and also appeals to more moderate
Republicans because he comes off less
erratic like Trump does
um and so he's a little bit more of an
official politician type aesthetic type
Vibe and people are tricked by that and
they think that Ron DeSantis is a more
moderate Republican and would be fine
and so DeSantis feels that Mike Pompeo
is making clear he's not trying to be a
trumpster
but his claim to fame is being Secretary
of State under Trump and he doesn't
really have the
Charisma the political abilities the
past successes in my mind to really
launch him into such a prominent place
in the minds of the Republican base to
defeat Trump or DeSantis just doesn't
seem likely but one of the things I've
been thinking about lately
would it be better for Trump to be up
against a bunch of people Mike Pence
jumps in the race Mike Pompeo jumps in
the race some other mic jumps in the
race
um we saw John Bolton jumping in the
Rays DeSantis and does that do more
damage
even when we know a lot of those people
have no chance of winning or
is it better for it just to be to stand
as first Trump and them really tear each
other apart
let me know what you think in the
comments
um if you're watching this on YouTube
definitely going to be an interesting
next to years